did you know that the man who
assassinated Mahatma Gandhi is treated
as a hero by many people in India the
shooting of India's revolutionary icon
was 75 years ago but it tells a lot
about the spread of the far right in
India today
let's take a look back in 1947 Gandhi
helped to lead India to independence
from the British with his campaign of
peaceful resistance earning himself a
place in the history books but just
months later in 1948 Gandhi was leaving
an Interfaith prayer meeting in Delhi
when a man gunned him down at
point-blank range his name was nathram
godze and he's been connected to two
right-wing Hindu nationalist groups one
was called the Hindu mahasabha which
blamed Gandhi and his religious
tolerance for preventing partitioned
India from becoming a Hindu Nation the
other was the volunteer paramilitary
group The RSS Godzilla and the RSS
denied he was an active member at the
time but that's been debated for decades
so after Gandhi's death the Hindu
mahasaba was vilified the RSS was banned
and godze was executed but the RSS never
went away no longer banned its now
widely seen as providing the ideas and
the blueprint for India's current ruling
party the Nationalist BJP India's prime
minister Narendra Modi who led the BJP
to election Victory is also a member of
the RSS many of Modi supporters want to
see India become a Hindu Nation some of
them have been attacking Muslims and
other religious minorities and many
Hindu nationalists now Revere godse just
last year a BJP MP described gaze as a
patriot godze even has a Temple
dedicated to him where his supporters
pray daily and as for Gandhi well to
many people it seems like the ideals he
fought for of a tolerant and secular
India are under threat like never before
[Music]
thank you